yeah so from from a physics perspective
uh
i i think
a lot of physics people will kind of be
clip about so well
entropy will cause everything to fall
apart um and that's true unless you put
enough energy into the system right and
then i i would think that you can you
can fix it right i mean that's that's
kind of the same thing as that you can
think of it like a house falling down
so say you have this this brick house
and over time the the mortar starts to
decay and the
the bricks start to fall off because of
gravity and fall apart um
but you can keep fixing the house
like you can keep putting energy and you
can keep rebuilding the house and keep
putting it back where it is and i think
that's kind of where longevity science
is we're trying to figure out how to how
to relay the bricks so hello and welcome
to the cheeky science show where in this
video i spoke with lloyd waits a
particle physics phd student at mit who
also hosts the sapien at mit podcast and
has interviewed nobel prize winners
legendary scientists and recently even
myself
today we spoke about the fundamental
components of the universe dark matter
to medical theranostics to discussing
why we age i hope you enjoy our
conversation
so hi lloyd thank you for joining me
today and welcome to the chicky science
show it's great to have you on
yeah thanks for having me on eleanor i'm
i'm flattered and happy
that's good to hear so um it's
interesting to have you on the channel
obviously because i've got a
biochemistry background whereas you do
physics and whilst i did physics a long
time ago was you know maybe not that
long ago for me um it feels like a long
time ago now um there's a lot of
concepts and fundamentals i feel like
i've either forgotten or maybe don't
appreciate so much that can still be
beneficial for the work that i do today
and more broadly thinking about some of
the changes that are coming in the world
you know every day and in the future
so i guess my first question is what got
you interested in physics and how did
you end up where you are right now and
we're not literally but doing a phd at
mit
yeah so um what got me kind of
interested in physics in the first place
were two things though i guess what kind
of got me interested in science broadly
were um
well the first thing was fiction right
so my uh my mom actually started me into
star trek at a young age uh and when i
was when i was little i would watch
spock and how he was obsessed with logic
and somehow i was kind of like that that
makes sense and in kind of an ironic way
you know logic makes sense um
but uh i always kind of
looked up to him for some reason and he
was the science officer and that kind of
drew me into science and then
um
kind of a
kind of a funny story when i got a
little bit older when i was in like
middle school um i was watching cartoons
all the time like like a kid would um
and then i got to the age where i was
like too old to be watching cartoons and
then people started making fun of me so
i said fine i'm not going to watch
cartoons anymore i'll like i'll watch
something else so i like scrolled up to
the next couple channels and that's it
was the discovery channel and the
science channel and the history channel
i was like you can't make fun of me now
i watch documentaries all the time and i
was in for a rude awakening when i
realized what that meant
but
uh and that was back when discovery was
really about like science and stuff and
so there are a lot of great shows on
there with like the old maichioku shows
and this was probably before neil
degrasse tyson even got super um in the
public eye
brian cox was another one who works at
cern now who i
maybe i should try and find some random
people i know at cern who might run into
him or something um but those those
shows were like very heavy physics and
astronomy focused uh they were very much
like trying to understand theories of
everything trying to like
trying to understand uh how the universe
works and why
uh planets and whatnot were um behaving
the way they were and i always thought
that was the coolest thing ever um
and
so
i i kind of when i was when i was going
into undergraduate i wanted to be an
astrophysicist
because i thought like i had the kind of
noble picture of galileo looking through
his telescope looking at all the planets
and whatnot and like all the beautiful
pictures of the hubble space telescope
and um i wanted to do theory i i wanted
to try and understand these kind of
theories of everything these these deep
layers of um
of
how the universe works and explaining
exactly where that comes from
and
so
i thought astrophysics was the way to do
that and as i got older i realized it
wasn't really it was more actually in
the particle physics realm and then once
i became a grad student in part of
physics my opinions on that have changed
on how exactly that that works um
but that was kind of my path on on how i
got there and it was also very much that
like
it was kind of solidified by the idea
that physics is is fundamental like
physics is kind of at the bottom right
like physics uh
describes electromagnet describes like
electrodynamics electrodynamics you can
kind of
wiggle your way into getting into
chemistry through that part and then
through chemistry you get to
biochemistry biochemistry it builds up
life and so when i was young and naive i
had this idea that like
uh
from the standard model you could build
up and understand all the laws of
biology right like obviously that's not
very feasible but like that was kind of
the idea and it was kind of like if you
had a big enough computer you could
figure it all out just by this one super
powerful equation that you ran long
enough and then you could kind of figure
everything else out after and everything
else was kind of an afterthought so that
was
what really solidified me in physics um
and that path has kind of changed as my
opinions about kind of
reality have changed and have set in as
i've gotten older but that was how i got
there so you mentioned that like you'll
see now you're doing particle physics in
your phd research and so my audience
probably are less familiar with these
concepts and so what are the kind of the
fundamentals as you say to understand
what is particle physics and what what
exactly is it that you're studying
yeah so the um
the spiel that i i usually give is
so
imagine uh in physics the kind of
ultimate goal right it is this theory of
everything it's this single unified
theory that
what i was talking about you start from
the bottom and it goes all the way up
and you have a strong enough computer to
run everything
um and can hypothetically predict the
future with this ultimate uh equation um
and the the secret of physics is uh that
we actually have one right it's called
it's called the standard model
people don't refer to it like that
because it there's a lot of problems
with it um
but the standard model as far as we know
does
do a very strong description of
electrodynamics of the strong and weak
nuclear forces uh
but it doesn't have gravity which seems
kind of silly right like gravity is one
of the most obvious ones like if the
standard model was the only thing then
like stuff wouldn't fall to the ground
and i wouldn't be sitting here
um
but i mean three out of four is not bad
that's that's a pretty good theory um
having
gravity involved is what a lot of
theoretical physicists are working on
now and trying to make a unified theory
but there are also several other very
large jarring halls one being dark
matter
dark matter is seen by astrophysical
observations to make up
uh i want to say 22 percent of the
universe
but the the precise um
uh calculations change or the estimates
change and then there's dark energy
which a lot of people don't even really
think about there aren't a whole lot of
ideas about it
that explains the universal expansion
um
and so the majority of the universe we
have no idea what it is and that's that
doesn't really fit into a very good
theory of everything that's being used
to predict the future
another one which is kind of a
low-hanging fruit i think is
neutrinos so there's a list of
fundamental particles typically you
might think of atoms but atoms are
actually made up of of neutrons and
protons and electrons and then within
the protons and neutrons there are
quarks that spin around and you can see
this this chart which is called this
which comes up in the standard model
that describes a list of all of these
fundamental particles um
and one of the more interesting
fundamental particles i think is the
neutrino um
there's more of them than there are
protons and neutrons by like
hundreds of orders of magnitude um it's
the most plentiful particle in the
universe and it doesn't interact with
anything uh so there's like there's
always the quote there are millions
going through your fingernail every
second right
but you don't feel any bump on your
fingernail because the cross-section is
so small um so neutrinos were actually
thought to be dark matter for a while
but when the estimates came out of how
many neutrinos there were and how what
their approximate masses could be um
they were eliminated as as potential
dark matter candidates they i think they
eliminated a small fraction of what the
dark matter was described to be but not
nearly enough
the thing is in the standard model
neutrinos are described to be completely
massless um they neutrinos move almost
at the speed of light if they moved at
the speed of light they would have to be
massless like a photon
that's kind of a fun uh sidebar is that
the speed of light is not actually just
the speed of light it's a fundamental
constant of speed um and so like if you
have any massless particle it will move
at the speed of light
so i know i think in russian they don't
call it
the speed of light they call it like the
fundamental speed
that's why it's always denoted c and not
actually denoted as the speed of light
yeah um
light just happens to be a a massless
particle that we interact with on a
daily basis and so we call it the speed
of light
you could also say it's like the the
speed at which information can possibly
travel
but anyway so a long time people thought
that neutrinos traveled at the speed of
light but they found out uh one that
they don't move precisely at the speed
of light and and two
that they
change their flavor or their their state
so
if you think of uh there are three
different types of neutrinos you have
your electron neutrino which couples to
your electron and has that has a
matching lepton number to to the
electron you have your muon neutrino
which matches obviously your muon and
your tau neutrino
and
if say electron neutrinos are produced
in the sun which is pretty common
because of the nuclear reactions that
occur in the sun and then they travel to
the earth you'll notice that you won't
get the right number of neutrinos
detected that you you should based on on
many of the solar models it was off by a
factor of three actually
and
part of the reason why was they realized
that these neutrinos are changing from
one to another as they travel this has
to do with
it's a little bit in the weeds but
basically it's because
there are two possible
uh descriptions of a neutrino that one
is describing a neutrino when it's
moving and one is describing a neutrino
when it interacts
and each of these states are actually
superpositions of the other
so when you have a neutrino moving it
exists in this superposition it's not
any of these three interacting states
it is
simultaneously an electroneutrino a muon
neutrino and a tau neutrino
all at the same time as it's moving but
when it interacts it can only interact
as one of these three things i see okay
like like classic quantum mechanics mind
bending nonsense um but this is this is
like the concept of quantum
superposition that you have
three different states that exist
at you have one state that exists as a
superposition of three other states
and so only the other way around as
something if something interacts or is
produced as an electron neutrino it
exists as a superposition of these three
other neutrinos
yeah um so that meant
strain because they had a mass
eigenstate and they had these uh flavor
eigenstates and you can see that they're
changing in order for it to exist in an
electron flavored neutrino state it
would have to exist as three different
mass eigenstates
to make that make up that superposition
but in order to have three different
mass eigenstates
they had to have mass because those
masses had to be different from each
other
therefore neutrinos were not massless
and the standard model had an
inconsistency in it
ah okay
yep so from from there the neutrinos
therefore needed to have mass and that
ended up winning a nobel prize um and
so from there kind of a whole bunch of
neutrino physics has fallen out i mean
the obvious question is well how much is
that mass um and so that's some of the
peop uh
joe famagio who's on my hallway he works
on a couple of experiments trying to
understand specifically what this mass
is
but there are some other things that
that come out into the math
that if you look at it closely you'll
see that in order for them to have mass
they also need to have a right-handed
counterpart they need to have a separate
type of neutrino called a sterile
neutrino and there have been hints to
this in experimental data
and so that's actually what i work on
and it's kind of a long convoluted way
to get there but
so
what i work on primarily is
to make because neutrinos are so hard to
detect because there's so there's so
many going through your fingernail at
every given moment um
instead of producing larger and larger
detectors which is the kind of the main
use of what's going on now or making
very very dense detectors that take
advantage of different scattering
techniques
my group works on an accelerator-based
neutrino to make this kind of neutrino
flood light right so instead of uh
making a huge detector to cover that to
be in some mine somewhere you have a an
accelerator that creates this massive
amount of neutrinos right next to the
detector and you could say okay any
signal that comes from this is
specifically from this source and you
can do all the neutrino physics you want
because you have so many neutrinos
cool so you basically just answered the
questions i was gonna like uh ask you
next anyways so
why is it so so you they don't interact
with anything these neutrinos so what is
it you're actually detecting and how
does that process work and sort of on
from that maybe a sort of dumb question
what is it
what is the role of these neutrinos you
say that everywhere so why are they
getting produced and how do they
influence things that go on in the
universe
it's just some oral exam questions
so
how you don't actually observe the
neutrino physically right like at the
end of the day what we're actually
observing and it's this is kind of an
important nuance in in all kinds of
physics is what we're actually observing
is
almost always light right um
and so what we observe in
the detectors that i work with is
something called inverse beta decay so
the neutrino comes in and interacts with
the particle inside the detector which
emits a flash of light
and then uh can also cause there's a
second signal that gets emitted that
emits a second flash of light and
cascades and whatnot the process is a
little bit technical and there's
diagrams that will explain it better
than my hand waving but it's called
inverse beta decay and produces these
flashes of light that are then picked up
by photomultiplier tubes surrounding the
detector
um and from there you can say okay there
have been these many flashes of light
and that means we have detected these
many neutrinos um and sometimes people
can get creative with saying okay based
on the uh
the detection times of where these
different photo detectors found the
light you can figure out actually where
within the detector it was set off um
and depending on how bright the light
was sometimes you can understand the
energy resolution as well okay see
and so what is it that you do like what
was your day-to-day like during your phd
and
what are you talking about
researching these stereo neutrinos but
previously they were thought not to
exist so
how did you find their existence and
then what kind of discoveries have you
made in your research so far
okay so i to be clear i haven't
discovered anything
no one has discovered zero neutrinos uh
and my project still isn't built yet uh
this is
i do a lot of design work um and
honestly on the sterile neutrino side uh
that doesn't actually take up most of my
day-to-day the majority of my day-to-day
uh
is depending on what project i'm on so i
would say the majority is actually
designing this accelerator so the idea
is to make it we're making this neutrino
floodlight this is a work in progress
this isn't something that has been built
yet this is proposed um
and the majority of my my day-to-day is
writing code that does beam dynamic
simulations actually so you have you're
i'm designing all of these these magnets
and electrode systems that shape and
steer a beam so that it collides with
the target so that it can produce these
neutrinos we talk about the neutrinos
because it's the end end result but a
lot of the hard work is actually
involved in making the system that makes
it work um
so my day-to-day is typically split
between two things it's either working
on these specific beam dynamics
simulations um or sometimes it's it's
phenomenological work like the the axiom
work that i've done
was finding cross-section estimates of
uh expected event rates of what these
axions would be doing inside this
detector and then say okay based on a
certain amount of flux in our beam
connecting that to how many actual
events we can see in our detector so
that we can do an analysis once the
experiment is up and running or more
more
kind of importantly in a proposal say
okay if we build this experiment what
are we going to be able to see and i can
say okay based on these calculations we
will be able to see this with this
signal and this confidence level and
we'll be able to rule out like these
experiments and whatnot
um
so
i haven't discovered any of these things
but hopefully in like five to ten years
when this thing is is built they'll go
back on my analysis and they'll say okay
these are the exclusions that we are
expecting to see and then uh based on
that we can say oh well
we looked in this region there's a
signal here and oh there's there's the
sterile neutrino oh there's the action
oh i see and so you've mentioned a
couple of times these axions but would
you be able to elaborate on what exactly
these are
sure so um
i mentioned earlier that uh one of the
glaring holes in
physics was
dark matter that there is how dark
matter came about i know when i was
first learning about dark matter i
didn't have an idea of kind of what it
meant or uh where it came from
so i i thought a lot of the time you'll
see sci-fi movies or whatever they'll
say like oh we have these dark matter
particles and the reason why it's called
dark matter is because we don't know
what it is uh all we know is there are
these strange gravitational anomalies
that we see in space
one of the first ones was if you look at
the speed at which galaxies rotate um
they should actually spin apart and all
the the stars and whatnot should be
spinning out into the galaxy or not into
the galaxy into the into the cosmos i
guess and specifically not be in the
galaxy because of the center of uh the
centrifugal force um but that doesn't
happen it gets held together because
there's some amount of mass that seems
to be invisible within uh these
galaxy clusters um
and
sometimes when people see that including
me when i first looked at it i was
saying well maybe people are just kind
of doing their their calculations wrong
maybe there's a modified gravity theory
that should be put in place to look at
this so
i think the most important piece of
evidence is the bullet cluster and
gravitational lensing that i don't think
it's when you go to dark matter talks
you see it a lot but
a lot of the time you won't see it
outside of that and basically what it
was
is you have two clouds of gas
right
so the two clouds of gas over time
because they they all have mass they'll
run into each other and they'll collide
and the two clouds of gas uh because
their their gas will kind of bump into
each other and they'll slow down they'll
kind of just blob up
right
imagine if these clouds also had a large
amount of dark matter inside of these
clouds well dark matter doesn't interact
electromagnetically which means it
physically cannot bump into each other
whenever whenever two dark matter
particles we don't know what they are
but we know that they don't interact and
interact electromagnetically and so they
can't bump into each other and so
whenever two dark matter particles bump
into each other they just fly right past
each other
and when we look at
the the bullet cluster which is these
two glass clouds going into each other
we see that we see these
gas clouds kind of stopping but if you
look at the the gravitational lensing
which is you can say is like
telescoping for for mass right if you
look at the actual mass distribution of
the gravity distribution
it's predominantly focused outside of
the gas clouds so the gas cloud center
in the middle and then there's these two
blobs of basically particles that have
just like passed right through each
other and didn't bump into each other
and didn't get stuck and so that would
indicate like there's
there's something making these large
mass pockets that is not interacting
with our telescopes but is creating a
very large amount of mass and so i think
that's really the smoking gun for uh
dark matter
and so i don't i don't know any kind of
theory that can describe that there are
some interesting modified gravity
theories that uh have tried to approach
it but i haven't heard any really take
off okay
um
yeah so
what are axions and what axions have to
do with this so there are there were a
bunch of different dark matter
candidates that have come out sterile
neutrinos were actually one as well um
because they don't interact at all they
interact they don't
have they wouldn't bump into each other
um
but they also don't have and they might
have a lot of mass but it depends on
there's there's different ways to kind
of kind of play with it and tune the
parameters to decide whether or not
they'd be dark matter um
but one of the more compelling ones was
something called an axion and the reason
why i think it's so compelling is
because it originally was not proposed
as a dark matter candidate it was kind
of found as a dark matter candidate by
accident
um
this gets into another deep in the weeds
particle physics problem but uh
there's
three fundamental symmetries in nature
uh that is
uh charge symmetry parity and time
symmetry and you essentially what it is
is that if imagine you have some
particle if you reverse all three of
these symmetries your charge your pear
tree your parity and your time
then everything should interact exactly
the same meaning like say you have an
electron it might take a second to think
about this it took me a while it took me
probably a couple months to really
understand this but
say you have an electron moving in this
direction right it has a negative charge
it's moving in this direction and it
pulls on whatever around it in that way
that should be identical to
a positron or an anti-electron moving
the opposite way at in that time right
because instead of pulling all these
objects in that direction forward in
time it's now pushing all of the objects
away backwards in time so the
interaction between these two things
should be completely identical
that's kind of a weird mathy
thing
to think about but it is basically that
if you flip everything everything should
behave the same in reverse that it does
all right so you mean like a mirror
image um or like
like if we literally just like stop the
clock and we turned back time things
would happen the same or what is that
quite right
sort of so a mirror image is one of them
parody is another word for for a mirror
image so that has to do with like
chirality right chirality in um in
chemistry is the same idea that uh you
have these these two parts that even if
you flip them around if you flip them in
a mirror they will become physically
different
so that's the first one that's parody
the second one is charge so all of your
electrons are now positrons the
electrons now have positive mass instead
of a negative mass
and so they will push instead of pull in
whatever direction
and the third one is running time in
reverse
so if you do all three of these things
instead of having the electron moving
this way or say yeah say the electron is
moving this way and you have another
charge here you have an electron so
normally two electrons would repel each
other and so this one gets pushed away
if you run it in reverse and you change
this charge
this is now a positron and time is
running in reverse
so what should happen is it should still
get pushed away
even if this is an electron because it
would be getting pulled because it's
opposite charges attract but it's in
reverse so that means it gets pushed
away because time is reversed okay yeah
okay i've got it
yeah so that's called cpt symmetry
and that's in a lot of theory papers and
it's i think it's a kind of an important
fundamental idea in particle physics
but
that's
a lot of it it gets deep down into the
experiments because of things like cp
symmetry
and what cp symmetry is is every once in
a while you can break off two of these
symmetries so instead of having cpt
which is always conserved you can
actually break these symmetries
individually
one of them being charged parity
symmetry so if you change the charge and
you make and you change the chirality of
the particle
there is an expectation that sometimes
that symmetry should be broken
and what was found is in the strong
force which is one of the four
fundamental forces i had described
before it has never been observed
experimentally which is weird it's
possible because there's there's a
parameter in the standard model that
could just be super super small it's
possible that this this uh
this cp symmetry is just very unlikely
to be seen and that's why we've never
seen it but it seems weird that it's
almost exactly zero
and so what was proposed to this was two
people named uh petite quinn uh proposed
a
additional symmetry that could be broken
um to make it so that this term would
always be zero and that the strong force
never violated the cp symmetry and that
would correspond with our experimental
observations uh and then frank wilcheck
and steven weinberg uh simultaneously
looked at this this paper by pitching
queen and realized that in the case of
the symmetry breaking there would
actually have to be a new particle that
would be a result which would be this
observa experimental observable
and that would be the axion uh and so
that's where it came from the the soap
cleaning up the strong cp problem the
strong cp problem being that we never
actually observe
this cp violates the cp symmetry
violation in the strong force um and so
to clean up that problem you add an
additional particle which is the axion
uh and frank wilcheck said well i wanted
a name particle after the axion soap
since i was a little kid and so now he
has produced these these axions um
and when they discovered this or well
they didn't discover it but they they
came up with this theory
um they
just they kind of looked at what the
different possible parameters were and
what the masses would be compared to
some of its couplings
and they saw that in some cases where
the masses
especially when the masses were
sufficiently low um and in in certain
cases where the masses were higher
that
the axion could actually describe the
dark matter phenomenons that we've been
seeing and so it was this very
serendipitous like oh wow here's this
interesting kind of pet project that we
found to find to understand these
experimental observations it could
actually be way more than that and since
then axion experiments have kind of
exploded and there are all kinds of
different axion experiments looking in
in different places and looking for them
at different masses and different sizes
and and different couplings
well it seems interesting right because
as you say it seems to be solving both
what is dark matter but also solving
this cpt problem right
right
yeah so that's that's why a lot of
people have have kind of moved over to
axions from other potential
dark matter experiments is because it
simultaneously solves more than one
problem and so wouldn't it be really
great if like if someone found it and
then all of a sudden these problems were
resolved so you think you have found it
or has is there still just theoretical
observations no no no no no
i haven't found the action
[Laughter]
i would be on my way to stockholm
[Laughter]
no so the paper that i
just put on archive
is about our neutrino experiment
actually it's our accelerator-based
neutrino experiment next to a big
neutrino detector and we said well
in addition to that you can actually
produce instead of just producing axions
it's actually possible to produce
instead of just producing neutrinos it's
also possible to produce axions in this
target
and when you produce axions and you're
next to this big neutrino detector you
can actually try and pick up
an axion signal
and do a detection how that's done is a
little bit funky it's like uh people
describe it as light shining through a
wall but
i can go into detail if you want or i
can just say that there are ways to
detect axions in a neutrino detector we
can leave it at that
well i guess so like the interesting
questions or obviously
why we study
particle physics is so that we can
address like how did the universe get
created understand dark matter and how
um
yeah the kind of like the big
fundamental questions about life but in
terms of more day-to-day use cases i
know that there's a lot of overlap
between using particle physics for
medical imaging so what potential use
does your research have in that area
yeah so
um
i said most of the time i'm actually
spending working on on beam dynamics um
and when you talk about using ion beams
the majority of ion beams aren't used
for particle physics experiments i was i
was kind of sucked into that by joining
the the particle physics division at mit
um
what the majority of them are actually
used for is to produce medical isotopes
so
uh if you go to a hospital and you say
you're getting a pet scan right when you
go to get a pet scan you have some
injection put into your arm
and then they put you in a scanner and
then they they look at whatever
tumors or whatever the tag is depending
on what tracer they put on on the
pedestal and what that actually means is
they are injecting you with a small
molecule that is attached to a
radioactive isotope that was produced
sometimes on on-site depending on what
kind of isotope it was or sometimes very
far away and it was made by this massive
accelerator
and
because we're making this massive
accelerator for a neutrino experiment
this massive accelerator is actually
possible it also makes it possible to
make far more of these really exciting
isotopes
so in the case of a pet scan what
happens is this radioactive isotope
attaches itself to
the tracer the tracer attaches itself to
a tumor and then it undergoes a decay
and that radioactive decay emits a
positron the positron uh annihilates
with the electrons in your system and
produces again light so your body is
acting like a kind of like a little mini
detector right
and then outside of it you have these
scanners which actually pick up the the
light signals from these from these
annihilation signals
um
basically understanding of the pest
glands was so it's the glucose that they
inject right so the idea of the tumors
they're more metabolically active so pet
scans work by it kind of lighting up and
highlighting what the tumor is
right so it varies a lot like i've even
heard of attaching uh radioisotopes to
neurotransmitters which i thought was
a little scary but also like makes a lot
of sense right if you're trying to do if
you're trying to do brain imaging um
but yeah so in the case of tumors what
they do is they've attached
radioisotopes to glucose the cancer
sucks up all of the glucose because it's
a glucose hog and then the isotope once
it's inside the tumor undergoes a decay
and then that's kind of i i work with
with
producing the isotope
not actually the tracer so i don't know
a whole lot about the tracers themselves
i just know that like you want to make
your different isotopes chemically
similar in order to use the same tracers
um but essentially yeah it gets gobbled
up by the tumor and it emits this
positron which is why it's called pet
scanning it's positron emission
tomography it's like fundamentally using
antimatter to like find tumors like
that's pretty cool
and
uh
so it's using the property again of
actually cpt symmetry a little bit that
you have this annihilation that happens
with a positron bumps into electrons
because there's electrons all over your
body in all of the different cells um
and that causes an annihilation which
produces two photons and then the two
photons um actually just kind of like
radiate and bounce around and produce
enough uh produce enough light that can
be picked up by a signal
by a outside detector and a pet scanner
but some of the other stuff that i think
is even more interesting is you can use
like
a similar idea so pet scans are like
something that people are a lot of
people are familiar with but you can
also use them for therapy and for
theranostics um so there's a lot of uh
push in the nuclear medicine community
to simultaneously do diagnostic
treatments and therapy treatments
so having a single isotope or a single
pair of isotopes that you can instead of
injecting someone with one isotope
trying to do some kind of therapy and
then injecting them again later on and
seeing if the therapy is working you can
actually do it simultaneously with
certain types of isotopes that both emit
a positron for pet scanning but also
kill physically kill the tumor and so
you can watch the tumor get killed as
the nuclear medicine treatment kind of
takes hold but that's interesting so
that's
yeah so that's that's one push um
i have i have a paper talking about that
too but so there's
one of the
one of the therapies
that i think is super exciting are
called alpha emitters specifically uh
actinium-225 um
and there's i haven't
i'm not sure if i can share the image or
not but there's this study from several
years ago that essentially showed a
malignant tumor
um
through
a person's body and there were
little black spots all over them right
uh and so this is essentially a dead man
walking right um and that's what allowed
them to do this clinical trial uh and so
what they did is they had octane 225
which emits four alpha particles and
alpha particles are a helium nucleus
right and so these helium nuclei get
emitted in radioactive decay and but the
good thing about alpha particles is
they're
large but i mean large on like an atomic
level they're still still atoms but
they're large enough that they actually
think of kind of like a bowling ball
they just like kind of run through
everything and stop because they lose
all of their energy but in a very small
area um and so that's perfect for if
you're putting them right next to a
tumor so if i mean very basically you
could imagine like okay i'm going to
inject these alpha emitters into a tumor
well then they're going to emit all of
their alphas actinium-225 has like a
four alpha chain that kills everything
over 50 micrometer radius everything
that 50 micro micrometer radius is gonna
be destroyed and there's not really
anything you can do about that it's not
like uh a lot of therapies where it's
kind of like uh
oh the uptake efficiency wasn't enough
or something like that it's you're
literally nuking the cell right with a
treatment like this um
but
you're not gonna be able to inject
it into tumors all the time so what
you're really doing is you're attaching
one of these things to a tracer say
glucose for example and then it finds it
attaches itself into the into the tumor
and then
undergoes this radioactive decay and
kills everything in that region
and the results of this are are
um i looked at this picture and i was
like that's it we cured cancer
yeah but it was it's crazy looking at
these images um because they took
someone who was just like
cancer spread all over their body
and it was gone within nine months they
were cancer free in nine months because
they literally just like nuked all the
individual tumors by attaching them to
tracers and what's that any because i'll
see i i mean
i know that the the cancer the tumorous
cells are more likely to take up the
tracer but is there also any
implications for the killing of like
neighboring healthy cells
yeah so the the first thing is you have
to make sure like the half-life is
sufficiently long uh you need to make
sure it has a sufficiently long
half-life um
so that it's not just like exploding
everywhere in your body right because
you don't want to keep that yeah
the other good thing is it's it's only
50 micrometers so it's it's pretty
localized um you uh you won't have
like
you're not going to end up with cells
that are are in the region unless you're
dealing with something that needs to be
super super localized like i don't know
if this could be used on something like
brain tumors i don't know if i would i
would trust that but i think there are
other people
there might be people working on that
i'm not a lot of the the innovation now
is done in two places one is where i
work and trying to produce more of it
and the other is in the tracers
and producing the tracers is certainly
non-trivial but it's it's not something
that i'm an expert in um so you need to
kind of make sure that your tracers are
actually being uptaked by the tumor and
not being not latching on to anything
else
um
but there's something i can do to help
with that actually and that goes back to
theranostics
so
last year there was a paper put out by
uh the department of energy
so um actinium-225 is kind of my my
go-to example of an alpha treatment um
but
if you want to see how the alpha
treatment is doing you need to put in
you need to do other types of imaging to
see how the how the tumor is progressing
um and you're not 100 sure where the
alpha tracers are always ending up right
because you're not actually imaging the
alpha tracers you're tr you're imaging
the tracers of whatever pet imager or
what or spec imager that you're using
um but last year the department of
energy put out a paper
using a new pet isotope called uh
cerium-134 um that was actually
chemically almost identical to
actinium-225 so you could use any tracer
that would be attached to actinium-225
and use it in crm-134
um and it was another there was another
one there was a thorium isotope as well
that they used for for an alpha
treatment
so
you could have a single tracer that
chemically attaches to the actinium-225
and to the end of the cerium and so
because the cerium just acts as an as an
imaging agent you can see exactly where
all of the tracers go
and so you don't have to worry if the
actinium is getting stuck in someone's
knee or something random like that it
would you would always be able to see
through the pet imaging exactly where
those tracers are going and so if you
did them simultaneously not only would
you be able to watch to see like how the
tumor is progressing over time with the
with the same tracer but you'd also be
able to ensure the safety of of the
alpha emitter yeah wow this is really
interesting technology i'm like i kind
of want to read more into it now that
you've mentioned it i guess that's why
there's been mouse studies or did they
go straight for this human patient
um so in cerium it's it's i think it's
just been mice i've only seen a mouse
paper um i wouldn't be surprised if
since then they've done like a clinical
study but i know
uh there are clinical trials going on
with actinium-225.
um the other thing with actinium-225 i
know in terms of like the approval
status is
typically when it's approved as a drug
it's not just approving the isotope it's
approving the isotope and the tracer and
like the full the full system
and so
if you want to have one for pancreatic
cancer you want to have one for this
type of cancer it's each is a separate
individual treatment that needs to go
through a separate approval process okay
which makes sense right like you don't
want to have a bad tracer no matter how
good the idea is when you got me
thinking so the idea is obviously
if you have a good tracer then the
technology is already there but if you
wanted to target a specific population
of cells you could do it using this
technology
yeah so i even heard one person was
using it to treat like
fungus like a person's fungus because it
was just like
it was able to just like kill everything
in the region so they just they had like
i think they had like some kind of
actinium cream
that they put on a fungus to kill it um
but yeah i mean it's used
it's looked into for tumors um but
it it's not exclusive for that by any
means um i'd be curious to see if some
bio people out there might be like oh
well this is perfect for like cell death
in this well i was going to say
senescence right i mean if you could
find some kind of traitor that's taken
up by you know a population of senescent
cells
maybe it was the fun well that could be
interesting can you
could you do an alpha therapy on all
senescent cells um
i feel like you could but it might not
be yeah no i i mean
i mean that could take this whole hole
into this analytics field and talking
about senescent cells which we're here
to talk about your research not my
research so i'm gonna stop talking
um well
so like like the actual roadblock there
i think that's a really interesting idea
because i think the actual roadblock
there
wouldn't be i mean if you could if
you're a biologist and you can magically
be like okay this is the senescence cell
like here's the tracer put put your
radioisotope on it um i think you could
do that but what i'd be worried about is
i feel like
senescent cells are probably like spread
evenly throughout your body right is
that it so we don't really know but yeah
they'll see classes it depends on like
the formation of them but you're right
so if you're going to kill things in the
radius or whatever diameter you said it
was
so that would affect
neighboring cells that potentially were
still healthy or like stem cells so yeah
i get that
yeah and i also
i mean i don't i don't think there's
been any crossover between senescence
and nuclear medicine yet but i would
i wouldn't be surprised if
the neighboring cells like right around
that like 50 micrometer range actually
becomes senescent uh because maybe
there's like i wouldn't be surprised if
because all of these cells have
literally just been nuked like an
inflammation
so one of the i mean so again bottom of
my stuff not yours um in terms of
therapeutics for cancer a lot of them um
use chemotherapy right which is meant to
just kill the tumour cells but the
caveat is that it also affects the
surrounding healthy cells which could
enter senescence and so you might clear
the the tumor cells but you end up with
semester cells whereas this approach
using um
like
nuclear physics the idea is that you
just directly you're only going to be
killing the um you only kill the cells
it's not likely that you're going to
cause a cell to enter senescence
although i guess that's probably not
been looked into yet
i i don't want to say that that's the
case because i don't know i don't i
don't think anyone does i would be i
would be shocked if anyone has done a
study looking at the senescence of like
bordering cells after alpha therapy but
that should be that's a great study that
someone should do that is not
sure no that's yeah super interesting
and so besides like
medical imaging then where else do you
see the overlap with like particle
physics nuclear physics and i guess like
research in biology or just more
generally in health research
[Music]
um
so
i i think there is more
uh overlap than a lot of people give it
credit for because i remember when i was
in an undergraduate there was my uh my
roommate and best friend that was a
chemical engineer and um
he he was having problems with just like
under i think it was
i want to say it was uh graphene or
something and he was under having
trouble understanding like why uh some
kind of molecule was stable um when it
had
uh a delocalized setup of electrons on
above and bottom um
and in order to kind of understand that
i've it was
easier for me to understand it because i
had an idea of
uh
an electron wave function
so imagine if you have
like a
benzene ring and you have i mean you
have your hydrogens up and up and down
your benzene ring uh and then you have
all of your electrons and you take an
electron out and it doesn't just like
crumple right like even if even if it
has a single electron taken out it
doesn't just like fall apart and i think
part of that is because
the electrons aren't physical dots right
the electrons aren't these individual
dots that are moving around in the the
benzene ring they form this distribution
they are
non-locally acting particles um they
they exist in this this
literally this kind of like
blur around the particle which means
their charge distribution is also in
that same blur around the molecule um
and so i know some kind of physical
chemists take advantage of knowledge
like this to be able to
have some funky tricks to be able to
um
find new types of of molecules and
whatnot i'm not an expert in that but uh
i i feel like i get a good intuition
from biology sometimes because of my
physics background um but i also think
that it it probably makes me a little
cocky sometimes or i look at it and i
say oh this is just some like physical
system and like it does this and i'm
completely wrong um so i think there's
some give and take okay in that case i
know that you're interested in longevity
which is how we first got connected and
so
from your physics perspective what is
aging and why are we aging
so
i mean i don't have a
outside of like the hallmarks of aging
that you see in a lot of papers and um
certain like theories of aging i mean
the basic way that i always kind of
assumed it was was just entropy right
and that's that's what a lot of people
will
consider is just the breaking down of
cells over time um and the breaking down
of genetic material over time or even or
epigenetic material
which i mean entropy is the i i've said
before that entropy is the greatest evil
in the world because it's it's
completely inevitable and it's uh kind
of unstoppable and causes all of the the
negative things that we think about
right so like aging death decay
destruction it's all it's all just
because of entropy because the lower
energy states um the kind of the macro
states that you do not desire are the
most probable because you only want a
certain subset of things to exist and if
you only want that certain subset of
things to exist
everything will fall away from that from
that one subset because it's just like
because
there are more possible ways for the
thing that you want to not exist than
for to exist
and so everything just kind of falls
away from what you want
and so i think aging is a lot like that
it's like i want to continue in the
shape that i am in
um
and
that that's just not possible because
like
i get dirty i uh i get i need nutrients
to continue to survive i need to
continue to put energy into my system to
be able to continue to exist at all
rather than not age
but
that's that actually kind of leads us to
to the next point is that is aging truly
inevitable i mean entropy is in some
entropy in a closed system is completely
inevitable um but i read this this
awesome quote out of uh david was david
sinclair's papers that is like
entropy is inevitable but aging uh but a
living system is an open system not a
closed system so you can continuously
put energy in and you should be able to
reverse the aging process because we've
seen that the aging process occur is
reversed in other in other animals such
as
certain types of jellyfish and then if
you also clone a cell you can see that
you're able to
have this
have a new organism produced without any
of this information actually being lost
so there's something going on there
biologically that i don't fully
understand um
and it makes sense from a physics
perspective that like if you have if you
continue to put energy into a system you
can kind of circumvent these uh these
ideas of entropy causing things to fall
apart um which makes me happy right
because i don't want to get old and i
don't want to die right
so like
yeah so from from a physics perspective
uh
i i think
a lot of physics people will kind of be
clip about oh well
entropy will cause everything to fall
apart um and that's true unless you put
enough energy into the system right and
then i would think that you can you can
fix it right i mean that's that's kind
of the same thing as that you can think
of it like a house falling down
so say you have this this brick house
and over time the the mortar starts to
decay and the the bricks start to fall
off because of gravity and fall apart um
but you can keep fixing the house
like you can keep putting energy and you
can keep rebuilding the house and keep
putting it back where it is and i think
that's kind of where longevity science
is we're trying to figure out how to how
to relay the bricks
um and how how to actually do that right
yeah
and that's not a question i can answer
unfortunately i can't either at the
moment but it's interesting that you say
that because i also spoke uh last year
with andrew still he also wrote a book
called ageless but his background
initially was physics um which she did
at oxford if i'm remembering correctly
so he had a similar like entropy it was
the was the reason um
so it's it's always interesting to hear
the different perspectives and so
obviously as you're coming to the like
near the end of actually one more thing
about entropy too um so
something that's kind of interesting
about
uh
a lot of arguments about thermodynamics
and entropy is that i mean
at first order people a lot of the time
will assume that life shouldn't exist
because of entropy right because here
are these these very complicated systems
that have kind of like grown out of
nothing right um but there is something
to be said about the
local increases in order compared to uh
global decreases in disorder
and i think i heard an argument once
that
because life exists we are actually
using
we're actually causing greater increases
in entropy because we're like creating
more heat because we're biological
systems than if everything was just kind
of sitting there well there's some other
arguments in protein and protein
interactions that the water molecules
they
become
more disordered as you bring two
proteins together because
um the kind of circumference like you
basically [ __ ] off the surface area
i don't know if that makes sense but
they're similar principles
sorry so if you have two monomers of a
protein that then dimerize um the
surface at the exposed surface area
decreases because they're now um
interacting together and so the
surrounding water molecules um there's
less of them when they're time rise as
opposed to individual and so the entropy
it becomes more disordered the water
molecules
so we call it like entropy induced
dimerization
yeah entropy is kind of a weird concept
especially just randomized
who also makes a very good point about
entropy
is that uh
he
he will state very firmly that entropy
doesn't exist and he he's actually kind
of right so how he describes entropy is
he basically says well entropy is a
description of how little you know about
the system
which is true because uh
hypothetically if you were to other than
like the quantum measurement problem
which is something no one's really
actually looking at
you can have a say you have some
perfectly deterministic system even like
a box of gas right and you had the
perfect idea of where each of those
particles were going it's deterministic
you can understand where each of these
things are going um but what you do when
you
calculate entropy is you say okay well i
don't i don't know all this information
i'm going to kind of make an educated
guess
about how this the system works
and based on that i'm going to say what
is going towards disorder but disorder
is really just like kind of a
description of the number of possible
macro states it's the number of possible
orientations that each of these gases
could be in and you can say okay what is
the probability that it's in like this
particular macro state compared to this
particular macro state and then
depending on how these different pieces
change uh you'll say it's either in a
high or low entropy state but that
doesn't really mean anything that's just
kind of like how good is your educated
guess it's not a like a physical
property it's just kind of a i guess a
mathematical description or even like an
error in your mathematical description
yeah interesting
yeah i i i thought that was a
cool take on entropy because it's like
entropy is always like oh it is a
fundamental truth and force of nature
but it's really not it's just like how
we how we look well yeah speaking of
fundamental truths so what are the kind
of
unanswered questions that you feel are
in the physics space at the moment and
um yeah what does the kind of next five
years ten years
look like and what sort of findings do
you think will make in this time frame
so uh i think
in in terms of particle physics i think
the the main unanswered questions are
basically how do we fix the standard
model how do we find these uh
how do we fill these gaps that we've
talked about what is dark matter why is
the universe expanding at an
accelerating rate uh what is the
neutrino mass are there additional
neutrinos because of this additional
neutrino mass what are their properties
um
and
is it possible that there is some uh
additional theory that could be unifying
these things um i remember on on your
question sheet that you actually had
like a what was kind of the hope of a
theory of everything or uh or a grand
unified theory um
and a lot of people think that it's just
never gonna happen including frank
wilcheck actually um when i interviewed
him he's
uh specifically said that
he doesn't think there's a theory of
everything he doesn't think it's gonna
it's going to be that that clean um and
it kind of makes sense like a lot of
people have been searching for this this
unification for um
for the three forces that we've unified
the standard model and gravity but like
there doesn't have to be one right like
it doesn't all have to be the same thing
it could just be like it could be like
the stator model plus like gr um sure
there there are some special cases like
around black holes where like there has
to be some kind of description that
unifies them there um where it's like
in this case this is what the properties
are sure but there doesn't have to be
some point where like all of the
fundamental forces are the same there's
no reason that they all have to be one
force it doesn't all have to like
integrate the same way that
electromagnetism did
um
but
i i think that's still one of the
leading questions especially in the
theory community of like
i know that a lot of people in uh
theoretical gravity for example um
i asked them what they're doing on their
thesis because they they were saying
i mean
if someone solves like the
the gravity quantum mechanics problem
with the quantum gravity problem they're
going to want to know about prison so
you can't be expected to do that for
your for your phd
and essentially what what they said is
they
generalize
uh
a different kind of problem so space
time the way space time is curved is
different depending on different models
and essentially what they do is they use
a model that they know is wrong
and they try and explore different
possibilities within that model and they
hope that one day when they find the
right model they can map their the
problems that they've solved onto the
correct model and that's their thesis um
i always thought that was interesting
and made me glad that i didn't end up
with quantum gravity because i wouldn't
be happy about that but like i also go
to their theses and i have no idea what
they're saying even though i'm in
particle physics i feel like they're
speaking wow
okay
yeah uh
so i i see their work with a lot of
admiration and maybe not the most amount
of understanding
um
so i i whatever it is i think that's one
of the problems in particle physics
today in addition to finding
these additional gaps in the standard
okay
and so you mentioned that um you spoke
with frank wilczak um who i'm just gonna
mention that i read his book
fundamentals recently which i is
fundamentals right but i highly
recommend reading because it
goes for a lot of the topics we've been
talking about today so that's a good
beginning if all of these concepts are
quite novel to you um but this was on
your sapiens podcast which you um host
at mit
and so i wanted to know um
what got you into that but also you've
spoken with many incredible people on
that podcast platform what are the
most interesting lessons that you've
taken from it
yeah so there's there's a lot of meat
there um so yeah i i met with frank
wilchick which is
uh a really cool experience we uh bobby
and i who's the the co-host on the
podcast um got to go to his house
actually over in lexington um
and did a full interview with him there
that's that's all up on youtube um
and
we've also had ray weiss on who did
gravitational waves um who won the nobel
prize for for ligo which was in the news
a couple of years ago um and that was a
that was an awesome interview he was
super energetic uh
and
but how how i kind of got started in in
zapiens was i i wasn't the actual person
that started sapiens it was uh one of uh
she was an undergraduate when i was a
first year graduate student i want to
say her name is uh sarah noosh and she
founded this i this kind of this group
that was devoted mostly to uh human
enhancement and and kind of
transhumanism um
and i
when i first went to graduate school i
was very on the cusp of working in
particle physics or working in in
biotechnology um i had had an offer to
work with with ed boyden uh who i
believe you either have interviews
potentially we'll be soon
we'll potentially will be soon
interviewing um
who's true he's truly an amazing guy
like
there there are a lot of people i
i've had on the podcast where i'm like
oh wow like he has a nobel prize and
he's just like a regular house yeah
speaking with him he's lovely it
yeah
ed was one of the few people where i was
like this guy is he's different like
he's he's special uh he's he's a truly
like brilliant guy um
and
so i have my opportunity to work with
him or to work with my current advisor
who is also just a a really amazing
advisor jana conrad in particle physics
um and it was a very difficult decision
but i ended up going into particle
physics but i still kept in touch with
ed um
and still very much was interested in
biotech so when this this group came
along that sarah news started and sarah
news was actually in ed's research group
um
i i hopped on it and i became pretty
deeply involved in it because i was like
this is this can kind of get my my
biotech itch
well uh while i'm in graduate school and
while i have this this great opportunity
at mit to talk to all these these random
people who i otherwise wouldn't have
been able to just kind of like knock on
their door
um
so
there are a couple of other there are a
couple other of us who have kind of like
come and go throughout the years um
and uh we started out giving talks at
mit
um where we would have post docs and
professors come in and give a lecture to
a group of students who wanted to show
up and then give people pizza and
whatever
um
and then we had a big seminar series
that ended up having like a thousand
people show up that had these like five
big guns of of george church and max tag
mark and david sinclair and ed boyden
and patty mays and joe paradiso um
and
that was a super awesome experiment
experience and then after that we kind
of like didn't really know what to do
after that
and so we started giving uh
more kind of like private seminars again
um
i i led a seminar with someone that i
had worked with at draper um who did
this like dragonfly technology where
it's basically like he kind of hacked
into the neurosystem of a dragonfly and
controls how it flies around with this
like mim
yeah it's kind of it's a real wild one
but yeah if you look up dragonfly with
with the the i being e-y-e at the end
you'll you'll find some of his stuff
um
so he gave a presentation we couldn't
post that one though because of like
draper
issues
and uh
we were about to do
the um book release for david sinclair's
lifespan
um
and we had like posters set up and
events set up and we were advertising
and then like two days before
kovid kind of started to really get out
of control and we had to cancel it
uh which i'm kicking myself for now now
that it's become like a new york
bestseller and everything he had been
showing us pre-prints he was super
excited for this event
and uh
it got cancelled and then we
and then it ended up being a best seller
and i'm like kicking myself because i
was gonna be like the host for it and
everything um
but then after that we i mean we were
all kind of adjusting to the code for a
while and being remote sarah neuch ended
up going to graduate school out in
stanford which kind of broke up the
group a bit
um
and then uh that was around the time
that bobby who's the the current co-host
came came on and started to get more
involved
and even though the podcast itself has
dropped my mic for a second uh even
though the podcast itself has only been
going for like a year uh for
probably like two years before that we
were actually doing
interviews uh with professors and we
would we would essentially go over uh
a paper or two um we'd have someone
analyze it we'd talk about it as a group
and we would always end up with more
questions i mean that happens at
at the end of every journal club where
you read all these papers and you think
okay uh
i think this is what they meant i'm not
really sure about their their like
methodology here i'm not really sure how
this works um
and so we kind of leveraged the fact
that we had this cool event and like
this this nice website to be like oh uh
can we talk to you for an hour over or
zoom and just like ask you about your
research and so we would do that and we
would have these these interviews with
like five or six of us and and the
professor uh and learn
all about their research and about their
paper uh and about what they were doing
that might not have been public yet and
stuff like that and it was it was really
cool and we got to meet a lot of awesome
people that way uh and then
bobby sent me uh a
link to like lex friedman's podcast
because he thought it would be cool i
had never seen it before uh
and i i wasn't going to watch it because
it was like three and a half hours long
and i got sucked in i watched the whole
thing in a day uh
and
i was like
well you know
you're sending me this link bobby i feel
like we should we can do this like we're
basically doing this already we just
aren't recording it uh
and so that's how it started we we kind
of pushed each other to do that and it
was i mean he probably was huge
especially in the beginning i i was
pretty low bandwidth and he was able to
i mean he built our studio he um found a
lot of the the equipment to purchase and
figured out how to get it like funded
through asa um and really put a lot of
it together
um and
so that was how the podcast itself got
started and i thought it was good that
we had it just so that we had a record
of all the people that we talked to and
that way um if we wanted to go for
funding or we wanted to talk to someone
else it's always good to be like see
we've talked to these other people too
like we're not just making this up we
didn't just like have this random zoom
call that the person may or may not
remember talking to a bunch of random
students like no it is on record two
hours like here these are all the
questions that we have um
at the same time it was great for me
because i got to learn about biotech
from all of these these people that are
uh really intense in the field um and so
uh
i kind of do i've said to some people
that i do each interview like three
times uh because before i interview
someone i'm typically like i look a lot
into their research i read their papers
i watch their other interviews and talks
then i give the actual interview and
then the third time i'm editing the
video again i hear it again so like by
the end of it i've absorbed so much of
that information
that i feel like i've learned a ton of
information about whatever subject that
they they were on um
and so we
we tried to focus kind of on biotech
because that was something i really
wanted to learn about but then uh
because we're in the physics department
we realized we're like well we can get
these cool physics people to come on too
and just kind of like bug them because
we we know who they are and we're in the
same department as them and so that's
how like frank wilcheck and and ray
weiss and and joe paradiso uh and a lot
of these physics people have have uh
gotten involved um
and then recently uh we have an
unreleased episode hot off the press
that um bobby actually interviewed a
rapper i don't know if you ever heard of
lupe fiasco i don't know
no no
so one of your listeners
and but he was apparently some like uh
visiting scholar at mit and bobby got a
hold of him he had no idea who he was
but i did i've been a fan of his for
years um
and uh
then he was like i came in the question
sheet had like lupe fiasco on the
question and she said bobby you got luke
if you haven't go on yeah would you do
that
i don't know i just like emailed him
um but yeah so we're branching out a
little bit uh
in terms of just like all the different
people that we've had on i mean i got to
talk to you on our show which was great
because i got to learn like what it's
like like as a biology grad student
which could have been me in a in another
life if i had if i had switched fields
um
and then learned about a lot of projects
that i never never would have understood
otherwise um
a lot of the organ on ship work that um
is done at emulate that i talked to
donald linger about i really loved i
thought that was some of the coolest
stuff ever um and that's something that
after i graduate it's something i want
to get more deeply involved in um
because i i think
i think if you combine that with a lot
of the uh things like
the yamanaka cellular rejuvenation could
have like a very high bandwidth in terms
of like research output and i thought
that would be really interesting um the
conversation i had with matthew
methelson was amazing just from like a
historical point of view um because he's
he's been involved in so much like
being part of discovering mrna which is
now like a household
name like
that's that's insane um
the methylene saw experiment which might
not be like a household name but it's
also like a lot of i mean i'm pretty
sure
what max sperman says
right
um
and i mean that's just like two of his
kind of like getting to know you
questions where his main thing was like
oh yeah i also did the international
bioweapons treaty
uh and was like
hanging out with henry kissinger uh so
that was that was a crazy interview and
i i'm really proud of that one
and he really enjoyed it too i was glad
to hear later that he he was showing it
to his friends and family which made me
very excited
um that that he liked it because
sometimes sometimes we interview people
and they really don't want to be there
um
mostly most people are good they're
polite but a couple of times um
after the interview they just kind of
leave
which is which isn't always the best
feeling so i was i was really happy that
he was uh excited it was a really good
interview as you recommend my viewers to
watch it as well if you find the sign
yeah and yes as you mentioned um i one
of the reasons why i was keen to talk to
you is that i feel like one thing i want
to do more on my channel was to kind of
demystify what it's like to do a phd
because a lot of people don't realize
what it involves and also there's a lot
of differences depending on their
discipline and even within like physics
like
different phd projects as we've already
sort of mentioned can be very different
and so um how have you navigated your
phd process now that you're coming to
the end of it and you kind of lead into
it already but what exactly is that
you're hoping to do when you graduate
yeah so um
navigating the phd process is kind of
weird and i feel like it probably
definitely varies depending on school
and in my case that at mit in the
physics department um i was really lucky
in that and specifically actually in
neutrinos and dark matter um the
literally like our neutrinos and physics
or neutrino and dark matter hallway is
super nice and super supportive um and
my advisor was also very supportive in
doing things like my oral exam and
making sure that i was prepared for that
and quizzing me every week and like
coming in on sundays to make sure that i
was like
um even if i didn't want to come in on
sunday she was there and she scheduled
these meetings um
and
uh
so
having a support group i think is
probably one of the most important
things in in graduate school because the
reality is is that uh
we've really
modern day has changed a lot in how
education is done
because of the internet because of
science channel site like yours and what
sapiens is trying to do is
give access to massive like these
amazing resources and people that
like like i said i'm lucky that i can go
and knock on these people's doors and so
by able to put these interviews on the
internet i hope that people can actually
get some of this this useful information
that i wouldn't normally have had access
to um
and
so
with
with the way the internet has like you
can find anything on youtube now like i
needed to fix an alarm system yesterday
and i was able to just kind of like
and figure it out um right like it's
literally literally everything is on the
internet and that's changed even like
the past 10 years right because more and
more content has been coming out so in
in terms of an education like going to
different universities has i feel like
has very minimal effect on your
education like raw because
for example all of mit's courses are
online mit opencourseware is all on
youtube you can go to all the lectures
and get all the course material that you
need online no matter like you don't
have to have a bachelor's degree you
could be a a high school student and you
can even like the notes i mean you can
watch the lectures right you're saying
that everything's on there
everything's online if you go to if you
go to mit open courseware um the
lectures are all online but they also
have the notes they have the homework
assignments they have the exams um
sometimes they don't always have
discussions
i'm sure no but like you need to be able
to grade yourself right you need to
figure out like what the answers are um
so i mean but all of the material is is
there like we live in an age where like
you really don't even need to go to
school to learn to go to these classes
so so what's the point right like what's
the point of going to these these
various institutions and it's really
like it's really the people you work
with um because the ability to go and
knock on someone's door or to to text
somebody who knows way more about this
than you do
is really what the valuable resource is
um because
there have been so many times i have
been so lost
like when i especially in my first year
there i i it's like drinking from a fire
hose i had no idea what was going on and
it's really helpful to be able to go to
someone and
ask them what's going on and have them
walk you through it uh and physically be
there to like go on the whiteboard and
uh talk about each individual step as as
things go on because science is hard
right like science is you're you have to
learn a lot of things that are very
complicated concepts uh that a lot of
the time are not made very clear in an
hour and a half lecture and are not made
very clear in a textbook that was
written 30 years ago
so it really helps to have these
individual people talk to you and on the
flip side being able to help other
people as well because you learn a lot
by teaching too um because you start to
see oh i have all these little gaps in
my own knowledge that i need to brush up
on and understand
um
and so i think that's definitely the
most important is to a lot of people and
i thought this was going to happen when
i went to mit and i was pleasantly
surprised that it didn't a lot of people
will try and isolate themselves and be
like i can do the problem sets all by
myself i can i can do this all by myself
and that was not the case and i don't
think people should should do that um
because i think human beings are are a
great resource uh to be able to help you
learn and to help get things done yeah i
mean that possibly i think people are
always willing to help you i mean
obviously if people can be stressed out
one day i'll be too busy but i think
people generally want to help um each
other
um
yeah i think that's definitely true and
you see it a lot
i noticed it even when i was in in high
school sometimes is sometimes helping
someone is an ego thing you're like i
can do this like i know this well enough
that i can teach it to someone else um
and there's definitely like an element
of pride to be able to explain something
to someone else um and also especially
i've noticed a lot at mit actually that
it will bug someone if they don't know
the answer
and so
if you ask someone and they don't know
it's going to bother them and they'll
probably and like i've had i've asked
someone a question
and then they didn't know the answer and
then i went and like tried to figure it
out for myself or i asked somebody else
and then they'll come up to me like
three hours later
yeah um so
that's yeah i mean i think it's
interesting what you're saying i find
the same thing obviously i can't you
know go and do my same process 10 years
ago like i
happened to have just done my education
process and the time that we live in but
it is interesting to um
well i also like i'm always amazed at
how much information is available for us
to sort of like learn any kind of topic
that you might find interesting um and
again like as you say having a sort of
platform to speak with people i mean
scientists always like to speak about
their research it's always uh just
amazing just to hear and learn about
different things and so i've interrupted
you again but you were going to tell me
about um
your next steps
oh yeah uh my next steps so
before i i came to mit i was working at
uh a lab called draper labs um
and
uh there are it's a dod lab non non for
profit that basically works mostly on
government contracts and department of
defense work um but also branches out
into into biotech and i found out this
morning actually does organ on chip
study so that's something i might look
into um they paid for my fellowship so
they're they're paying my tuition and my
uh my stipend while i go you have to pay
for your pc um
so well
it's kind of funky so
uh it depends on what the degree program
is but in physics kind of the rule is
you do not pay for your phd someone pays
for it a lot of the time it's an advisor
sometimes it is a fellowship through the
university and sometimes it is a
fellowship through some external source
a lot of the time it's like the national
science foundation uh is one of the more
common ones um
if you're in the military uh then
there's also a lot of military
scholarships as well um
and then there's these other like pseudo
military entities like draper and like
lincoln lab that will pick out
individual people and pay for their phds
in their stipend um and so
having that fellowship was actually
really helpful for me because then when
i applied to mit i could say well i
already have funding you don't need to
like take up the fellowship money from
from these other students and i i really
think that
helped my chance of getting into mit as
a graduate student
and at least like kind of put a blip on
my on the radar of the the admissions
committee um to see that oh this is like
it's a free student i'm i'm free labor
like please take me to one university
that was i mean that was kind of the
attitude um
but i think i think that really helped
and made a difference um
i'm not committed to go back there i
probably will because i i enjoyed my
time there um but there are also other
groups that i think are really
interesting um and i've gotten
job offers from like the visa when i
talked to i mentioned donald lingard
earlier uh the institute that he founded
the v institute i thought was super
interesting and i might apply for a job
there um and then there's
uh life biosciences does the show has
some of the ip for cellular rejuvenation
and also slabs is another one that works
a lot in cellular rejuvenation which is
something i want to work on after my phd
um but i don't have any experience in
that so i'll have to see if they'll even
want to take me
but those are some of the options of
what i'll probably be doing in the next
couple of years but i i think i'm i'm
flexible to how that's going to go
interesting yeah i mean it's interesting
as well that i feel like the further
i've progressed into biochemistry and
like i guess the way that the way
scientific research at least in biology
is you get very focused and more focused
and more focused on whatever it is
you're trying to solve
um but i kind of one of the reasons i
like doing the channel is that i get to
talk and uh learn about other areas and
say physics is something that i've
always did it like up to a level and
even slightly in my first year of
undergrads but then just you know as
soon as i chose biochemistry it was like
pretty much like forget everything just
focus on biochemistry and now something
i'm kind of like this is actually quite
interesting i think i want to learn more
about um i say it's interesting that
you've kind of had a similar thing where
you went heavy into particle physics and
now have these other interests and
understanding biology better um
but given your expertise in physics i've
just got just a couple of like more
quickfire questions kind of like when i
think of physics what i you're asking
about probably
about like fundamental symmetries and
like what are neutrinos and and how does
the standard model work those are all
the hard ones no like how to make this
work
yeah but i think i mean there's a lot of
um interesting questions in physics and
so one of them i guess i mean nice it's
more also related to um computer science
but a lot of talkers about artificial
intelligence and more agi artificial
general intelligence and
i think for me like um the interest is
what are the time scales on these things
and how would that affect our features
so
i mean i'm not an expert and and am i in
ai or ml i have one machine learning
paper that was very like
very niche in in terms of accelerators
um
i do a lot of reading on it uh but
i mean some people think agi's around
the corner i don't i don't know about
that uh
there's
some the i think probably the most
exciting prospects is the stuff not
necessarily open ai but a lot of the
stuff that open ai is working on that
has this idea of kind of a like a
co-pilot i mean literally co-pilot with
their with their um with their new
product that kind of like helps you
write code based on on visual inputs um
i think that's
one it keeps away from the the fear of
agi where it's kind of like it's people
are still in the loop but i also think
it's probably going to be easier to do
the more autonomy i think i thought the
other day probably the
the biggest explanation of mastery is is
automation right so if you completely
under understand how to do a system then
it can be fully automated um which means
it's really hard to fully automate
systems um in any kind of way whether it
be ai or even just like mechanically
right like in the old days you had like
physical automatons that you had to like
understand each of the pulley systems to
make sure that they could do something
but um
in ai it's just as difficult like people
are talking about having ai write
novels or things like that and that's
gtp3 is working on that but whenever you
read a novel budget gp3 it's terrible
right because it's all over the place
and it it makes sense for like a
paragraph at a time and then it turns
into a disaster um
i saw there was a thing in the news a
couple months ago about some google
scientists
who
claimed that their lambda computational
model i saw that too
yeah and it was immediately snuffed out
by like everyone in the ai community um
and
i actually read the transcript about it
because i was very curious um
and the things that got picked up by the
news were the very typical annoying
pieces that uh
they're like oh it said it didn't want
to be shut off i wanted it said it was
scared of dying and i mean that's that's
like very common i mean we've had
code that does that's just the 90s it's
like when i
if i say do you want to die say no right
like that's not that's not a sign of
intelligence um but the there was
something in the transcript that did
really
intrigue me and no one talked about in
any of the press releases where
he asked it to tell him a story about
animals with like a a moral theme and
there was it was a story about an owl
and then afterward he did he described
he asked it to
give like connections to what each of
the characters represented
which is something i've never seen ai do
before and it was able to accurately
describe the representations of each of
the characters and even identify to one
of the characters and explain why he was
able to or explain why it was able to
identify with one of the characters
which i thought was really weird um i'm
not saying that that's consciousness but
i think that's
that's something that hasn't been talked
about at all in that transcript which i
thought was very interesting
um
so
you have groups like deepmind that are
are trying are basically trying to make
agi and i think if that ever happens it
will be extremely revolutionary because
now you can have kind of like free labor
now you know you can just like print out
copy print all these agi's everywhere to
be able to like replace graduate
students um but
uh
so
i don't i don't think that's such a bad
thing i think
i don't know how soon it will be but i
think it will make
a lot of things easier and we'll
probably increase our our productivity
yeah and then the other thing as well
like in terms of the energy that runs
these things uh obviously there's still
a lot of talk and hope about nuclear
fusion which i guess the summertime does
overlap maybe with your research or not
so i
i share a lab with the fusion people
they're literally of labs
literally overlaps
oh yeah um so
i'm in the plasma fusion and science
center i'm i'm on the plasma side
because i have like an ion source that's
about this big and they're working on a
on a massive reactor that's like the
size of a building and i i get like one
room and they have like the rest of the
building but
they um
but i can't see any of their stuff
because it's all like proprietary and
uh like very hush-hush i hear rumors
swinging around there every once in a
while
um i know that recently
lawrence livermore achieved ignition but
i don't think it was a super sustainable
way
um and there has been there there's kind
of like there's weird approaches to
fusion because like we know fusion is
possible and humans have achieved fusion
um that's that's something that's tiny
tiny like oh we achieved fusion
well yes and no we've actually achieved
large amounts of fusion right uh a
hydrogen bomb is a fusion ball like we
we do fusion all the time and a hydrogen
bomb you can even argue is that like
it's an example of ignition we have
we have put in far less energy into a
hydrogen bond than the amount of energy
that gets put out and so there were
there was talk for a while i i think
some of it ended up becoming classified
and some of it was just kind of
kind of died out because it wasn't very
practical of basically trying to find a
way to use uh weapons like nuclear
weapons as an energy source because that
is a demonstration of how fusion can be
done at ignition um
and
so
that's that's one way and that's
somewhat similar to the way livermore
did it livermore used basically a ton of
lasers and then fired it at this single
pellet and they were able to achieve
ignition that way but i don't know how
how sustainable it is like i don't know
how many of those pellets they're going
to be able to
use i'm not an expert on that um and i
don't actually know anyone on that
experiment um so i i can't ask and then
there's the people at mit that are
making uh a tokamak which is basically
this this massive donut that that makes
a highly confined plasma um and the
thing that we've people have been
working on tokamax for a long time and
they haven't been able to achieve fusion
but it's basically because they don't
have a strong enough magnetic field to
have the confinement tight enough but
now they have stronger magnets so
hopefully the the confinement will be
tight enough to to achieve ignition
um
i don't i don't know where that's going
to go uh i've heard good things and i've
heard bad things um i don't have any
inside information if i did i probably
shouldn't share it uh
but i i really don't um
you know again fusion is is something
that could be really amazing and could
totally change like our our energy
footprint uh and the way that energy is
achieved
but
fusion has been 10 years away for the
past like 50 years so there's also a
healthy amount of skepticism i think
yeah
um and so also you have a
a breadth of knowledge in this field and
so um
where is the best place or best resource
materials and you've already mentioned
the mit open um platform already but
where can people go to learn more about
physics or
just explore some of these topics we've
discussed
um so to learn more about physics uh it
depends on how deep you want to go that
i think that's probably the biggest uh
thing you could trip up on would be
if you
like if you're a complete novice at
physics like
watching my interview with with frank
wilson might not be the best place to
start because i start going in on like
on field equations and stuff that's
probably not the best like that's
probably like undergraduate level
physics um if you're like a complete
novice then i mean there's tons of other
great youtube channels out there like
veritasium was something that i i loved
when i was an undergrad uh the coolest
thing i ever learned about physics was
from a veritasium video actually um
and uh
like minutephysics they they they're all
these uh oh the other one
up in adam that's that's one i've
actually
[Laughter]
she's great she taught me things that i
didn't understand like i i i i think you
said yeah
friendly yeah i can put you in touch
yeah yeah um
but yeah there's there's a ton of
content on youtube i i personally think
a lot of the time
i've seen cartoons of like
professor i need help and then they just
kind of like sprinkle resources and like
paper citations at you and i've never
found that particularly before i always
think i mean when people ask me
something topology i always say just go
to like the sort of very fundamentals
like i guess even an element of maths
you would need before you want to
step into physics
right so like
personally that's why i like youtube as
a platform so much more because
i find explanations on youtube
especially nice ones with animations
like your videos um
are are typically much clearer and
easier to understand than trying to
dig through every citation in a research
paper
because i get totally lost and i don't
end up actually learning anything um and
then sometimes i'll
or in textbooks some there are some very
well written textbooks like uh when i
was in undergrad
uh resnick and crane was it was an
excellent textbook that was the textbook
that like changed my mind that textbooks
could be useful
and
sometimes they can be great but a lot of
the time they can be awful
so
i think find a resource that works for
you and stick with that and
especially find something that like
excites you and gets you interested um
because especially like when i was
learning physics in undergrad there was
i think it was
the beginning of my third year is where
i really felt like i started to get it
and it really all started to click and i
think a big reason for that was because
i would get my my problem sets done and
i'd figure out my stuff out and i'd be
like cool now i have time to do
something that's interesting to me and
then i go and i watch like physics
youtube videos because i it wasn't
because like i needed to learn more
physics just because i was like
legitimately what i wanted to do it was
something that was interesting to me and
i think that's something that's really
important to understand a concept that
you want to do is you can't just like
you can grind through it and that's
possible and you can be you can be
strong-willed to grind through it but it
makes it a lot easier and you're
probably going to be much more likely to
stick with it if it's something that you
legitimately enjoy and you found an
interface that like excites you and gets
you very interested in it and that for
me that was that was youtube yeah no i
agree i'm also always watching youtube
videos um
great platform so obviously youtube's by
looking where they can go to find out
more about uh sapiens but where else can
people go to find out about your
research um and yeah the kind of things
you get up to
oh
uh
i mean our
group has a website but i don't i'm not
sure how how well updated it is um
i do if you like look at my name on
google scholar you'll find a bunch of my
papers
which will describe a lot more about my
research
and that
if you also if you look at my name on
google scholar it will be very widely in
range because i think i've said before
isadar is for me has split off in like
six different things um icidar was
originally a neutrino experiment um
but then because of its applications it
also turned into a dark matter
experiment it also turned into a
potential for medical isotope
development it also turned into this
like new way to produce accelerators and
a new way to like couple uh low energy
beam transports and and new way to uh
inject beam into into cyclotrons like
there's a lot of individual pieces that
will be split out um so
in terms of if you if someone is
interested in particular my research
they can also just like email me
elway said mit.edu like i'm i'm
not too afraid of getting spammed if i
do then i'll i'll figure that out but if
i get too many emails i think that's a
good problem to have so this whole time
i've been speaking to a potential future
nobel prize winner then
[Music]
i i i i don't think so um
i remember
freeman dyson at a void two who like
who i i would love to aspire to be one
day freeman dyson even though he's like
one of the
fundamental people not only in in
physics but also like in science fiction
creating the idea of the dyson sphere
and also like uh being the real person
behind fineman diagrams i mean fineman
kind of like made his squiggles and
whatnot but freeman dyson was the real
person that formalized it
also a friend of matthew methelson by
the way
uh
but uh freeman dyson never won a nobel
prize and when he was asked about it he
said it's like well i can't keep my
attention on a single project long
enough for me to ever get a nobel prize
i like to bounce around yeah uh and
i i agree with that i
get distracted way too easily and that's
part of why isadar has split off into
six different things um because i get
distracted on on different projects and
now i'm like oh i like longevity oh i
like organ on chips and that has nothing
to do with my things
so i need to i need to finish my thesis
and then i can start getting into these
other additional projects but i i
guarantee you like five years down the
line if i'm working on organ on chips
and longevity i'm gonna find something
else that interests me and i'm gonna get
pulled in that direction so yeah nobel
prize winner i i am not well i wish you
the best of luck with finishing off your
phd and yeah best of luck with whatever
career path you decide to choose and i'm
sure we'll talk again in the future it's
been great yeah having you on the
platform today
thank you very much it was great to see
you again eleanor
so everything is a wave but also
particle but the thing is is that uh
everything you can think of everything
actually basically as a wave
but it's really when something's a
particle it's actually just a really
really tight wave
so
when you talk about
a
double slit experiment for example and
you look at the distribution patterns if
you look at the distribution patterns
with fine enough
intensity you'll actually see with
regular particles that you also will get
an interference pattern and people have
done this up to things as large as bucky
balls actually
so
when you talk about the heisenberg
uncertainty principle of like you can't
understand something's position and
momentum at the same time it's not
because like as soon as you as soon as
you see the position the momentum goes
away
they physically are not well and like
you it doesn't
you can't they aren't simultaneously
measurable the reason why is because and
one example that you hear is that oh if
you
shine light on it then it changes its
its momentum and then that changes its
position that's not a good explanation
so a better explanation is think of it
like a wave so say you have some you
have like i'm standing here with a rope
and i'm wiggling my my wave back and
forth if i if i make really sharp peaks
right and i and i whip it back and forth
i can say okay the position of the wave
is just that one lump
and i have a really well defined
position on that but i don't really have
a good understanding of its momentum
because like i don't have its frequency
i don't have um the energy that's
traveling in that because i am not able
to describe its frequency but if i do it
a whole bunch of times then it's super
spread out right and you have all these
these waves going around and because you
have all these waves
like all these different like uh troughs
and what peaks and troughs through the
wave you can now get a good
understanding of its frequency but you
have no idea what its position is
because it's now spread over this this
large distance
and so the main thing with position
people are used to talking about
position in terms of absolutes that's
like this is this one individual piece
right but position exists as as uh as an
integral it exists between these two
separate positions and so as you shrink
that down more and more you get less of
an ability to actually measure the
frequency of an object which means you
have less of an ability to look at its
momentum so literally based on how they
are defined if you look at them from a
wave perspective that's what particle
duality is particle wave duality is it
has nothing to do with like people say
oh i made an experiment that can measure
them both at the same time no by
definition you cannot measure that okay
so it's not like an experiment it's not
like a technical experimental limitation
it's just by definition
yeah and it's also not something that
you can like out clever your way to do
it it's like it is a definitional
thing that uh
when
like position and momentum have to be
separated because of of how we define
position and momentum
that's the it's the same thing with like
with the eigenstates i was talking about
before the flavor and um
mass eigenstates like
you cannot simultaneously measure the
flavor of a neutrino and the mass of a
neutrino at the same time because they
exist as superpositions of each other
the mass is made up of a superposition
of being all three simultaneously the
electron the muon and the tau neutrino
and the electron neutrino is by
definition made up of the mass states of
mass 1 mass 2 and mass 3 of the neutrino
and they cannot exist separately they
are by definition those three they are
superpositions of those three